I think you're acting Jennifer in this
film your range shows that you're on
your way to a meryl streep young career
and and I just want to say that your
performance in this film in this series
cements Katniss Everdeen as an iconic
figure
like I Indiana Jones and Rocky Balboa I
know I have a friend I'm a teen friend
of mine her mom her mom and dad both
have cancer and she still lights up when
she's looking forward to new Hunger
Games Movies and she's like Oh Katniss
would still smile Katniss wouldn't give
up so you do have an impact where in
that way so I guess my question just is
you know this has had such an impact and
these movies have been so successful on
Catching Fire
I believe was the first female led movie
do we never went the box office since
1969 and has helped other female movies
get made so with that I mean what do you
feel do you feel the impact a of this
character and B since we always look
toward the future there's rumors that
while Studios really wants you to be
there
Captain Marvel would you ever want to do
that combined you know I'm playing that
sandbox with Bradley and Chris Pratt and
all of those people
first of all thank you that's the nicest
thing I've ever heard of my life thank
you
I feel the impact of being a part of
such a huge movie that does so much for
so many people I mean it would be
impossible not to and I think that this
character is so overwhelmingly
supportive of women obviously and and is
iconic I don't feel a personal impact
like I have and I think that if you ever
become aware of that then it kind of
takes away from it a little bit so it's
just kind of it's the movie and the
characters and they kind of have their
own life and it's kind of like your
avatar self I don't know
you